- [Narrator] Olympians train
for almost their entire lives,
with the goal
of winding up here.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
And that goal comes at a heavy price.
- It costs a lot.
It really, honestly does,
between the training and the traveling,
coaches' fees, it's quite a bit.
- [Narrator] It might pay off
and they can wind up here.
- Because a complete
breakfast with Wheaties
is good tasting and good for you.
- [Narrator] But to get there
requires years of financial investment.
- You're gonna be in a club program
that's gonna cost about 5,000 a year.
There's also fees to be paid
for going to competitions.
If you go away to an away
meet, you're gonna travel.
You may fly. You may drive.
You're gonna have to stay at a hotel.
All of those expenses add up.
- [Narrator] Even relatively
accessible sports like swimming
can cost athletes thousands every year.
Those expenses start as a child
and only get more expensive over time,
costing Olympians and their families
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in hopes of making it
to the Olympic games.
Here's a look at how much it costs
to become an Olympic swimmer.
(start gun buzzes)
Unlike other sports,
there aren't a bunch of
things you need to buy.
The cost of equipment is
subjective to preference,
but competitive swimmers
use special swimsuits
called tech suits, which can add up.
Men's tech suits like this
one can cost up to $400
and women's can cost up to $600.
- They could last one
meet, three or four swims.
It all depends about how
long you wanna wear them,
if they rip or tear or wear out.
The suit, it fits very tightly.
If you buy two, three
or four suits a year,
you're spending 2,000
bucks on bathing suits.
- [Narrator] Swim caps and
goggles are not as expensive
and can cost up to $300 per year.
And there's one more piece of
important equipment, a pool.
Swimming schools like
SwimLabs, a USA Swimming
officially recognized
professional swim lesson provider,
has locations all across the US.
Their location in Westchester, New York
offers private lessons
that cost $349 per month.
Regardless of where young
swimmers learn how to swim,
competitive swimmers will need
access to Olympic-size pools
for real training in the sport.
This usually means
joining a club's
competitive swimming team.
- [Swim Club Instructor]
Welcome to Meadowbrook.
It's the swim facility where a Phelps
and fellow Olympic medalist, Katie Hoff,
both got their starts.
- USA Swimming's number
one ranked swim club
in the United States is NCAP
or The Nation's Capital Swim Club.
In 2021, a club membership
in the Gold 1 category
for elite swimmers at their
Washington, D.C. location
will set a swimmer back
about $5,860 per year.
Swimmers start swimming
for their local clubs
at around 8 years old,
but usually will start no later than 12.
- There's a lot of club
programs in the country.
In metropolitan area,
there's well over a
hundred different programs.
And across the country,
you're talking about thousands of clubs.
Without club swimming, we
wouldn't have an Olympic Team.
- [Narrator] They continue
to compete for clubs
until they reach the collegiate level,
where many of them begin swimming
for Division 1 universities,
and some continue both.
So, by the time kids
reach the college level,
they've already spent 16 to
$40,000 on club dues alone.
In 2019, USA Swimming had 412,000 members
in over 3,000 clubs who paid
more than $22 million in fees.
They're the governing body of the sport,
responsible for organizing events
and recording official
times for national rankings.
Registered members pay
an annual fee of $60.
That fee allows swimmers to compete
in sanctioned competitions.
And one of those sanctioned competitions
are the Olympic Trials.
According to Coach Collins,
some elite swimmers
might seek private coaching
to be more competitive.
And depending on the coach,
private coaching can run a student
more than $1,000 per month.
Total expenses can vary
widely from person to person.
USA Swimming estimates
expenses for Olympic hopefuls
can be anywhere from 25 to $40,000
for proper coaching, equipment,
training and travel each year.
And depending on the
swimmer's training program,
they may also need a
budget for other costs
like a nutritionist, physical therapist,
or a gym membership.
The cost of competing in
any non-NCAA competitions
that collegiate swimmers enter
will come out of their own pocket.
Swimmers who choose the collegiate route
get access to all the necessary
amenities and facilities
they need, as well as
physical therapists, trainers,
coaches, and doctors.
Olympians like Michael Andrew
chose to skip the collegiate route
to focus all their efforts
on Olympic training.
However, that means the
cost of their coaching,
training, travel, entrance fees
and lodging is all on them.
- It is much harder to
be an individual athlete,
training by yourself in
reaching those top levels.
- [Narrator] Since 1978,
the United States Olympic
and Paralympic Committee
has not been funded by the US government.
So, US Olympians rely on
grants and sponsorships
to offset the out-of-pocket
costs for their training.
USA Swimming gives yearly
stipends to top swimmers
on the National Team.
They also provide bonuses
for swimmers who make it
onto the Olympic Team.
USA Swimming spends an average
of $10 million per year
in support of National Team athletes.
And according to them, most
Olympic and Paralympic hopefuls
make less than $20,000 a year.
Coach Collins says there
are sponsored clubs
who can afford to pay their swimmers
to be a part of their team.
- 'Cause you need to have money to live,
you need money to train,
and you don't have that money.
Who's gonna help you do it?
- [Narrator] The cost of
being an elite Olympic swimmer
is a full-time investment of training,
both in and out of the pool.
As in most professional sports,
the best athletes earn
the biggest paychecks.
And in swimming, those paychecks
come almost exclusively
in the form of large
individual endorsement deals
and sponsorships.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
(gentle music)